of X equals 3x minus 2 but that's when X
is less than or equal to negative 1 and
f of X equals 2x plus 4 and that's when
X is greater than negative 1 and I'll
have a link to how to actually graph
these piecewise functions another video
I did you can take a look at that if you
want to see how to graph them but
basically when you see f of X what
you're thinking yourself is this is the
Y value this is the output and it
depends like if I have an x value that's
less than or equal to negative 1 this is
the part of the function that I'm on
this is a equation that I want to use to
calculate that value but when X is
greater than negative 1 then I want to
use this part of the graph this part of
the function this piece okay so to speak
and so that's how it works so basically
let's look at this first one we've got F
of negative 4 equals blank ok let's see
so whatever is in the parentheses you
can see this is the x value this is the
input and is negative 4 less than or
equal to negative 1 yes so that means we
want to put negative 4 right in here for
X that's going to be negative 12 minus 2
which is negative 14 so that's our
answer
now the next one F of negative 1 well
you can see this is a negative 1 this is
negative 1 but notice this is equal to
this is not equal to so that means
negative 1 is going to go into this
first equation here in place of X so
what we have is 3 times negative 1 minus
2 that's negative 3 minus 2 which is
negative 5 and then the last one f of 7
okay is let's see is X greater than
negative 1 yes see 7 is greater than
negative 1 so that means we want to put
it into this second equation here 2
times 7 right plus 4 that's 14 plus 4
which is 18 so that's our answer so you
have to figure out which part of the
equation that you're on and then apply
it to that part